Hello everyone and thank you for taking
the time to join us today.
I'm excited to walk you through our
automated code creation, or AQC solution.
When an unstructured mail is sent with
key details such as job information,
the originator property information,
and client info,
the AQC tool intelligently extracts these
fields.
Once processed,
the system immediately generates a code
and sends an automatic success
notification back to the user,
which includes the code ID and the
details of successful code creation.
Users can then track codes progress by
accessing the AQC Tracker dashboard.
Using the generated code ID,
they can quickly navigate to the
activation page.
At the activation page,
the system auto populates the Code Basic
task with key information extracted from
the original e-mail.
Users can then modify or update any
details as necessary.
Once this information is verified,
the task can be completed by simply
clicking the Next button.
Upon completion,
all clients information and other
critical details are automatically
updated in the system.
Users can instantly view the status
originator and any other relevant details
of the code,
ensuring everything is accurate and ready
for follow up or next steps.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.